they called for me to be cut out the
broadcast and suspended by the regulator
today my journey on the show ended but
the journey with him still is going
going life is short do not sell your
soul for fame or
Fortune defend against a rapid spread of
microplasma pneumonia AKA white lung
disease using black resins CIT packed
with immune boosting properties CIT has
been scientifically proven to promote
respiratory Health aiding in oxygen
absorption while also making the body
infection resistant strengthen your
family's immune system ahead of the new
outbreak this winter don't forget to use
my discount code Alid dawa for 15% off
enjoy asalamu alikum brothers and
sisters you're fired Jenny you're fired
goodbye remember Dr Lord alanar whatever
his name is for that matter he himself
is a Zionist for that matter let's just
make that very categorically clear even
though Dr ASF MF has said that he had
nothing to do with it I'm sure he did
I'm very sure he did let's be naive
about this matter yeah so we've had Dr
ASF munaf who was on Apprentice for that
matter apparently I don't know I don't
really follow it and there's an offshoot
show of it or something like that for
that uh for that matter and he got fired
from it or got canceled why did he get
canceled what did he say that is
troubling that is being accused of
anti-Semitism what could it possibly be
did he deny the Holocaust did he say the
Jews deserve what they got that the Jews
should be exterminated that the Jews are
like this or like that no no no no no
none of that no no none of that yeah
none of that nothing to do with any of
that by the way guys yeah zil he's
talking about Zionism a fascist
nationalist movement who don't even
believe in God but use the Bible to
justify their deeds by saying amalaki
killing men women children babies which
idea for do and not just IDF not just
Prime Ministers not just the interior
Minister not just the defense
minister you have your pro Zionist in
the UK you're Tom dickin Harry who just
walk in the road just go about his
business who works in the local bakery
whatever Zionist Who and the people have
spoken to in the park who said we don't
see children as I don't see the a gazan
Palestinian kids as innocent do you
accept that Israel killed innocent
Palestinian children I don't think
they're innocent whoa that's the thing
is I don't think they're innocent this
is from the bottom top top to bottom
they are all singing from the same tune
so Dr Asif maaf had this to say guys
I've got nothing but support from you
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah I've literally got
hundreds of messages replies DMs I
cannot reply to all of them so thank you
all above all keep the people of GZA in
your dasas as well life is short do not
sell your soul for fame or Fortune I
know people out there who are doing
stupid Tik Tok dances and and music in
their videos they're trying to go on the
back of Fame do not compromise your Dean
cuz W Allah will open up doors for you
you can't even imagine last night all my
witness doors opened doors opened like
you can't even imagine honestly I'll
tell you one day but never compromise
your Dean keep Allah first and he will
open up doors for you but thank you for
the support guys I appreciate you 8:00
p.m. tonight so guys he is doing a live
Tik Tok go join it and find out what
exactly happened but it's very clear now
let's go and see some of the stuff that
he said that deem they deem it the
pressure that was put on BBC of
anti-Semitism let's see what it is he
said they did me dirty a Lobby pressured
the broadcaster and they Rel and they
relented they will only ignite a bigger
flame in my belly we have him Allah yeah
so they said they called for me to be
cut out the broadcast and suspended by
the regulator today my journey on the
show ended but the journey with him
still is going going never sell your
faith for fame always keep speaking the
truth especially in the midst of a
genocide true anti- Zionism is not
racism or anti-Semitism Zionism is not a
race or religion it is a few hundredy
old cult The Mirage of Western freedom
of speech has been exposed exactly
apparently two weeks ago he wrote that
zionism's mask is falling and accused
Israel of weaponizing the Holocaust to
push another fascist ideology and the
likes of that I mean what part of that
is not true what part of talking out
against a specific State a terrorist
State a specific government who is
committing outright genocide a massacre
as we speak killing over 30,000 innocent
people and this is where you see the
double stands and the hypocrisy the
utter double the The Mask has dropped
the Western World mask has dropped the
big fat lie of freedom of speech bull
crap right now you can see and the far
right scumbags like dogs like Tommy
Robinson and the far right bastards yeah
scum dirt bags what happened to freedom
of speech man what happened to Muslims
are the untouched you know nobody can
criticize Islam what happened to all of
that the only group of people that
cannot be criticized or dare to even be
spoken against is the Zionist they are
the only ones that should be immune so
much so that they would say that if you
was to have objective news articles
objective news they're saying that's
even aiding Hamas that you cannot make
this stuff up yeah they are trying their
best so the far ride you dirt bags you
scums I dare you to come to speak his
corner I dare you guys come to speak
Corner come face to face with me what
happened to freedom of speech what
happened to you know Islam says you know
go doing this the things that you
accused us of is exactly what Israel the
zionists are doing by their scripture
the land that they stole to the genocide
that they're carrying out they are
quoting their scripture word for word
letter by letter line by line yes and
they are committing actual genocide by
killing inoc woman children that you
accused we Muslims apparently do where
where are you gone why are you silent
what's happened why are people like Dr
assive being kicked out for speaking out
against the genocide and I salute him
where are all those influences that we
spoke about Muslim influencers who' been
on the BBC yes bake off this off that
off whatever where where are you not a
single Postman not a single Postman not
a single post so the fact that he put
this on the line and put which what his
religion to teaches him to speak out
against unjust Justice even if it's
against himself or his King he enacted
on that even if he lost whatever and
he's so brave that people are now
reporting the the the lobby yeah the
Jewish Lobby for that matter I don't
even the probably Zionist Lobby yet
reporting him to get him CU he's a
doctor yes I don't know what it's called
GMC or GLC whatever it's called yeah to
report him and he's boldly given his
number he say you can report him it's
fine no problem at all He's a brave man
and I salute him for standing up to what
is right because Allah subhana tal is
the provider they can try to take all
the St stuff away from you yes your
career this or that W Allah is
sufficient to the Believers Allah is
sufficient for us so I want to salute
brother doctor as if I'm not mistaken I
think I met him in a Birmingham event ET
in leester I met him for that matter but
may Allah bless and preserve him inah
please please carry on what you're doing
inshallah he did absolutely nothing
wrong and let me tell you something Lord
Alan sugar he's definitely big play
played a massive part in this and you
can see brothers and sisters the utter
double standards and hypocrisy of the
Western World of the freedom of speech
and the democracy is absolutely bull
crap bull crap R they are liars they are
under the disguise of this they are
trying to show us that they are people
of you know freedom of choice and freed
religion no the only group of people
that you are not allowed to criticize
which is funding lobbying yes lobbying
people individuals senators in States in
in America yes is the Zionist Lobby
nobody else yes and the whole world has
seen their reality and may Allah carry
an exposing them and you know what Lord
alanar You're Fired yes you and if you
end on this note and anyone that suppos
it let me tell you something you're not
going to be fired you're going to be in
the fire in the Hell Fire emotional damn
it so brothers and sisters that's all I
want to say inshallah let's carry on
supporting Dr Asif inshah he's going to
do a Tik Tok you can check that out
where he's going to explain what exactly
happened I believe Alish is behind it
he's saying is not I genuinely believe
that and the BBC shame on you guys you
guys are not impartial you are biased
and you are utter Hypocrites you cannot
even say anything against the genocide
that is happening as we speak brothers
and sisters may Allah subh bless you
guys that's all I have to say till next
time